I I feel as though I'm being pretty
harmless.
>> Sabrina Carpenter, she just dropped
Man's Best Friend, her entire album.
>> When you consume material like that, it
actually causes changes in your brain
that can be on a on a somewhat permanent
basis.
>> And and what's damaging to to that is
you gather this following of innocent
people and then you just tank them when
you,
>> you know, get depotous.
>> So when you're sitting there and you're
listening to a specific type of music,
it does more than just impact your mood.
and it gets more complicated.
>> How does something like Sabrina
Carpenters's music, her music videos,
how does it affect you in your brain
psychologically? That's who we're going
to discuss today. Alex, welcome back to
the show. You're a nurse practitioner
and you're here to really talk about the
neuroscience according to some studies
you found.
>> And uh Scotty, you're always here. So,
>> thanks for having me.
>> Welcome to another show.
>> I love it.
Um, yeah. So, Sabrina Carpenter, she
just dropped Man's Best Friend, her
entire album. There was a lot of outcry,
outrage about this specific album cover.
What do you guys think that is?
>> I can't imagine why. I don't know.
>> There's things making me uncomfortable.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Why?
Sometimes it shocks me.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, obviously, um, she is
portrayed here with a man holding her
hair and her in a, uh, he's a he's the
dominant figure. She's in a not dominant
position, right? Like, like people are
saying
>> it's it's controlling. And it's
interesting because I would say her
music is very much kind of
feministleaning.
>> And so, there was actually a lot of
people from the feminist side who were
against this, who said like, "No, you're
showing that the male the men have
dominance over you sexually." even maybe
it's slightly abusive. Obviously, the
conservatives were also not very happy
with it. But, uh, I would just want to
look at the backside of the album that
you see here, her record. Let's take a
look at what's going on over here. What
do you guys see?
>> Man's best friend. You got a dog collar.
>> Yeah.
>> Her basically has a dog on the front
cover.
>> Yeah. So, so I mean, I think everything
like this is is is up to interpretation,
but what I'm seeing is obviously there's
a dog, right? And obviously a dog is
called man's best friend,
>> but she's kind of putting herself into
this image of like she's man's best
friend, but she's in this
non-dominant position where she's
subordinate to the male figure and he is
holding her hair like you're holding a
leash.
>> You know what's sad to me is like God,
you know, he made us in his image. He's
he's given us this beautiful like we
were to be the ones that were running
this planet, right? And uh the devil
just loves to twist and taint this and
and like make you almost act like an
animal.
>> Like you're not like the top, you know
what I mean? And it's like there it's
like putting something out there that's
like really horrible or bad and then
trying to like promote it as cool and
good. You know what I mean?
>> Right. Yep. Well, this is true. Uh I do
think it's fair to kind of let her speak
for herself and why she chose this album
cover. And after this, we'll go into
some of her more popular music,
including Tears, the music video and the
music that just dropped just a couple
days ago. or a brand new single.
>> I think to me it's so up to
interpretation, but um
>> what's your interpretation? That's what
matters.
>> Interpretation is being in on the
control. Being in on your lack of
control and when you want to be in
control. Like I think as a young woman,
you're you're just as aware of when
you're in control as when you're not.
And I think some of those are choices.
And I think for me, this whole album was
about the humanity of allowing yourself
to make those mistakes, knowing when
you're, you know, putting yourself in a
situation that will probably end up
poorly. Um, but it's going to teach you
something. So, there was a lot of
different meanings. It's there's just a
lot of pointing fingers for, you know, I
mean, at that point, they hadn't heard
the project. They don't know me. They
don't know my intentions. They don't
know the stories I'm telling. So, I do I
try to take it with a grain of salt and
also know that like my fans that know me
and know the person behind the music
look at that photo and they know exactly
what it is. And people that have no idea
who I am absolutely look at that photo
and go like, "Where are her parents?"
>> My parents actually saw the photo and
they loved it.
>> Wow.
>> I just I always wondered that, you know,
if you got on a billboard and you were
like not dressed on the billboard, would
you go like, "Hey, mom, guess what? I'm
on a billboard.
>> Some parents do.
>> Like,
>> yeah,
>> that's weird. I would be saddened if my
daughter was like doing this.
>> Mhm.
>> I think she's actually said in
interviews that her parents are actually
proud of her,
>> which I'm like, man, that what a twisted
like uh world that we have today where,
you know, pe your parents are are proud
that you're going and, you know, kind of
exposing everything.
>> It really speaks to like the need for
parents that have stand standing for
morals, right? teaching your children
these values and and how to respect
yourself and how to respect other people
and you know I think she she's basically
probably coming from a mindset like like
hey look I can do this thing as I want
to and why are you getting upset at me
but you know if you look at it like
every action that I make m has the
potential to affect someone else you
kind of have to wonder like you know of
course people are going to say something
because you're influenced by this you
know
>> right right and that's something that
we're going to discuss in this show like
how does this actually influence other
people and even children? So, uh I found
a study by Chrisalis L. Wright. She's a
doctor and Michelle Kra. They both work
or worked at the time of writing this
study for the media and migration lab at
the University of Central Florida. And
they came across some really interesting
stuff when it comes to how music video
specifically affect women when they see
sexual references, right? And this is
specifically about when you watch as a
female, which relates to me, when you
watch music videos where women are put
down or or or are degraded. Now,
obviously, this particular um album
cover is not a music video. And
actually, in the majority of Sabrina
Carpenters's music videos, she actually
is on top as a female. Like, she's the
one that is in power and the males are
not. So that's why I said it's more of a
feminist kind of point of view. But I
wanted to pull this up anyway in light
of the album cover and how it affects
you, right? So these researchers say
that 53% of pop music videos contain
some form of sexual reference.
>> So it's actually 79% of R&B, R&B, and 78
of rap. But we're looking at pop music.
So 58% of pop music videos contain some
form of sexual reference.
>> Music videos.
Additionally, Zang found that frequently
viewing such music videos is related to
more sexually permissive attitudes among
listeners. Remember, these are females
that they're talking about. Sexual
references occur in music lyrics as
well. Lyrics often contain explicit
sexual messages and mu women in music
videos are often objectified by being
scantily dressed, which is what happens
pretty frequently in Serita Carpenters's
music videos. And dancing suggestively
and provocatively. lyrics often contain
demeaning messages of men in power over
women which you saw on her album cover,
sex as a top priority for males, the
objectification of women, sexual
violence against women, women being
defined by having a man, and women not
valuing themselves. Additionally,
exposure to such messages has been shown
to promote risky sexual behaviors.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Do you remember do you
remember the last um show that we did
that we were kind of talking about some
of the um the sex in the media and what
that kind of like did for people with
ratings if they just watched I think it
was like four videos or five videos. So
when they asked what should the consent
age be? They'd say like 16 and a half or
whatever like this. They would show them
a few videos. We're talking like six
videos and then all of a sudden ask them
what should the consent be and it was
significantly one to two years lower
only by observing a few videos.
>> So yeah, if you're watching this, you're
going to it's going to break down your
natural like, you know, defense against
getting involved in this early.
>> Well, why do they do this? I mean, it's
because sex sells.
>> I mean, that's that's why you have
subliminal messaging, which you guys
have done videos on before, where
they'll hide that word sex. hidden in
different advertisements specifically
because you sell more product that way.
So at the end of the day, a lot of this
is just about the bottom dollar.
>> That's right. That's right. There's a
lot of Yeah.
>> And then that's the interesting thing
too. What people noticed is that when
she came from Disney, she's a Disney kid
from from um
>> the Disney Channel.
>> She was this most innocent character.
She actually started dialing a little
bit of music. I think she released about
two albums or so
>> before she actually became this kind of
persona. And you can Google a lot of
YouTube videos where they say it seems
like this was a marketing strategy. She
wasn't getting off, you know, she was
she was known, but she wasn't like
worldwide famous known. Now she's like
Taylor Swift famous known.
>> Do you know why they do that? When they
work for Disney, they actually sign
contractual agreements that if you work
for that Disney organization, you cannot
engage in this and this and this and
this and this. those those those lives
are meticulously crafted in the
beginning to not get involved in this
kind of stuff. They actually
contractually cannot do this kind of a
thing. And so it's interesting. That's
why you see so many of them squeaky
clean and then they step out on their
own. And and what's damaging to to that
is you gather this following of innocent
people and then you just tank them when
you
>> you know get depart. Miley Cy Cyrus,
Britney Spears, Justin Timberlake,
Olivia Rodrigo,
>> all of them.
>> And parents may be initially, you know,
kind of watching what their their child
is watching, you know, oh, what are you
watching? And then if they see one or
two videos, they assume like, oh, well,
that's a good clean artist, right? They
can listen to that one, right?
>> And then they don't continue to watch as
the career may take a significant
downturn.
>> Which that happened to Taylor Swift. She
had this very ultra pure image at the
beginning.
>> Country singer.
>> Yeah. this country singer, you know,
small town girl, that type thing. And
then as time progressed, it has it has
progressively gone, which you guys cover
that in your Taylor Swift documentary.
>> We did. We did. Okay. So, here's another
study. Uh there were three
professors/ass assistant professors at
the University of Amsterdam and they
surveyed 1,24
Dutch adolescents. And so, check out
what they found.
So it says using data from a nationally
representative three-wave panel survey
among those Dutch adolescence structural
equation modeling showed that viewing
sexual music videos by male artists
increased the acceptance of female token
resistance i.e. So they explain it the
notion that women say no to sex when
they actually mean yes. So this idea of
like, oh, when they say no, they
actually mean yes. That idea grew by
watching these sexually explicit music
videos, right, among adolescent girls,
but not adolescent boys. Furthermore,
viewing sexual music videos by male
artists influence girls acceptance of
token resistance indirectly via
effective engagement. So, so if let's
just say you have a daughter. Mhm.
>> Let's say your daughter, she's a
teenager now. She watches this kind of
music video stuff, she's going to think,
"Oh, actually, when they say no, they
mean yes."
>> Mhm.
>> So,
>> Mhm. Or like if I if I if I don't want
to, then I need to say yes.
>> Does it work at the reverse? You know,
like
>> Yeah. It's like
>> it's just confusing your mind.
>> There's there's no good street. I I
think this is the number one thing why I
I was very careful with my daughter and
and growing up I didn't show her all
those Disney princesses things and stuff
because I wanted her to be
>> focused on the beauty of her inside not
this like exterior you know it's it's
>> the beauty of the character
because that's what a lot of the Disney
princesses are. They're like this like
not even a human being can be the shape
that they are.
>> Right. Right. So yeah I can imagine I
can only imagine like how confusing this
is to little kids as they're trying to
figure this thing out. Yes. So, we'll
actually have a a video of a little kid
that went to a Sabrina Carpenter show. I
think there she was the age of your
oldest son
>> and the parents took her there. So,
we'll have that in just a second.
>> Oh, wow. See, you know, there there
should be uh prevention of allowing kids
to go into some of these concerts where
they're doing some of this stuff and yet
you you see young kids going in there.
It's like
>> Yeah. So, let's take a look at some of
her most famous songs, her hit songs.
So, some of these songs, the music
videos on YouTube are actually in the
double digits of the millions when it
comes to the views, which is crazy. And
this music video dropped last Friday.
It's tears, heavily sexually explicit
lyrics. Uh, and uh, you know, I I
watched I watched it and I was like, I
don't think I want to watch it again.
You watch it too, right? Research only.
>> Research only. And
>> you were watched it with your wife.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And And honestly, it kind of
shocks me that they can that this kind
of stuff can be out there in society and
it doesn't get more backlash. There's
there's not as much backlash. Now, there
is some people it it's kind of divided
the internet. You have some people that
are on the feminist camp that say um
that she's empowering women by, you
know, being strong and confident and
doing what she wants and that type
thing. Um but then you have other people
that say, well, she's degrading women
down to just a sexual object basically.
Um, and so that's I think that it it
does degrade women to have this kind of
uh thing out there, you know,
>> and I think it's actually interesting
that you make that statement because um,
have you heard of
Fight the New Drug?
>> Yeah.
>> You have?
>> Mhm.
>> Have you heard of it?
>> I don't think I have.
>> So, it's a non-Christian, nonpolitically
nothing website. They're not they're not
siding with anything,
>> but they are actually against
pornography and they're showing you
studies
>> about pornography and effects it has on
you.
>> I maybe I have heard of them now. Yeah,
now that you mentioned it, I think I
have.
>> So, they actually show from studies that
when you watch this kind of sexual
content in pornography over and over and
over again. Yeah. You're you're you're
actually objectifying women. Yeah.
>> And you're actually changing your
mindset about a woman instead of being
this beautiful creature of God that
she's actually just an object for your
sexual pleasure. Well, and this is where
you get into the neuroscience
standpoint. When you consume material
like that, it actually causes changes in
your brain.
>> Um, that can be on a on a somewhat
permanent basis. I mean, you're
permanently changing your brain
structure to some degree. Um, and the
problem with that is that when you have
adolescents that are viewing sexually
explicit material, SEM, in the research
studies, they'll refer to it as SEM. Um
earlier consumption of SEM uh leads to
earlier uh uh first encounter with with
sex um and also higher risk sexual
behavior like unprotected sex, things
like that. So when you have people that
are consuming sexually explicit content,
they're more likely to be doing things
that have long-term consequences. You
think about um uh having children in in
your teens, you know, before you're
married or anything else, you know, you
have teen teen moms out there that uh
that can really mess your whole life up.
>> Um it can ruin your whole life where
you're now just trying to make ends
meet, just trying I mean, you're not
going to college, you're not doing a lot
of the things to further your yourself
and further your career and make sure
that you're you've got a stable footing
in life. Right.
>> So, and that's also going to contribute
to um more single parent households.
>> Mhm.
>> So, single parent households, you look
at some of the research and if you just
go out, you just Google some of the
research behind single parent
households.
>> Um children that are raised in single
parent households,
uh look at the crime statistics, look at
look at the the um completion of of
college. Not that you can't. There's
there's kids out there that do. But if
you look at it as a statistical hole,
you're it's really degrading society.
>> Yeah. Kids will often do what their
parents do. So you'll see probably a
repeat scenario when those kids get to
be in that position as well. So
>> yeah, it's is you don't think about the
choices that you make are it's like a
wake, right? It's affecting lots of
things down the road and you know, yeah,
man, it's like this is this this is not
good. Well, and actually in her music
video, uh, Tears here, actually, um, she
actually changed the ending of it. Did
you see that? She changed the ending in
the music video because originally it
had her taking a a stiletto and killing
the guy, like throwing it through his
chest at at the end of the music video,
but it actually got changed to where
like I think like a tree falls on him or
something now.
>> What?
>> Yeah, there was there was uh there was
news about it like where she
>> I've seen it with the stiletto.
>> Yeah, it's changed. I watched it the
last night with my wife. I watched it
last night. Last night with my wife and
a tree falls on him in tears,
>> dude. Well, let's take a look at the
music video for Tears.
>> Babe,
>> baby,
I'm so glad you're okay.
>> Wait. No.
>> I've been looking everywhere for you.
>> You died earlier, I thought.
>> Babe, what are you talking about? No,
it's a it's a thing. It has to someone
has to die every video.
>> Wait, what? I'm
>> sorry.
>> Why are you being weird right now?
>> We'll always remember you, though.
>> He was a nice one, too.
>> We have to give the people what they
want.
>> You know, there's a lot of things that I
I I see wrong with this on many levels.
not just the, you know, sort of
sexualized thing, but it's like
desensitization of somebody losing their
life.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> I mean, that's really a serious matter.
And and to even play lightly like
whatever, you had to die for the video
like is is I think psychologically
wrong.
>> Well, this is the point that I want to
make. The Bible says that at the end of
time, we're going to see these kind of
things where people are wanting
violence. They want sin. Lovers of
pleasure.
>> Lovers of self. Exactly.
>> Although the love of many will wax cold,
right?
>> Yes. That too.
>> You know, I'm sitting here watching this
and at the end, what did she say? She
said, um, we have to give the people
what they want.
>> Exactly.
>> And and so she's sitting there and I'm
like,
>> what about the coliseum where you had
thousands of people that are sitting
there with a thumb up versus thumb down
and
>> and so I'm like, okay, so are we going
back? I mean,
>> we have to give the people the death
that they want.
>> I think we're getting back to that
point. Right. I think they needed to go
back to that point
>> because because we are being prepared
for when Jesus comes again, but we know
before that there will be the great last
struggle. Right. Right. And so, how do
you ever get the majority of society,
the utmost utmost majority of society
prepared to eventually persecute
faithful Christians
>> unless you are constantly prepping them
through stuff like this where they're
okay with killing people.
>> And you think about the the stance of
the faithful Christians, right? Like it
talks about in in Revelation, there's no
guile in their mouth. There's no deceit.
They're they're they're the people that
are reflecting the character of Jesus
the most. And it's like how you going to
get a bunch of people to kill somebody
that's like kind-hearted, loving,
selfless.
>> Like that's not easy to do. I mean, you
can understand somebody who's a fanatic
and out there waving his AK-47. Yeah.
Take that. That guy would be, you know,
easy to to make as a target. But
somebody that's really kind.
>> Yeah.
>> It's only through desensitization.
>> It is. And I've actually found a study
that I'm going to show you later on that
talks about this actually desensitizes
you.
>> So, but I want to look quickly.
So, this is her website. I took the
screenshot probably like 3 days before
the album dropped. And look at the
bottom left corner. It says most wanted.
So, this is her store, her web shop. The
most wanted items are a t-shirt with
lingerie on it. This is what people buy
the most. and a deck of playing cards
with
this on it. It's Sabrina Carpenter on
and it says short and sweet. Um, and
busy woman. We know what she's referring
to. 18005 ft of fun cuz she's around 5t.
And then one of her playing cards
actually has handcuffs on it. I mean,
>> what? And then to think that who is her
age range, right? We'll take a look at
that soon. But it's not my age. I'm
already too old for Sabrina Carpenter.
I'm not that old. I mean, some people
think I still go to college, but I'm 31,
everybody. So, so it's younger than me.
And And like you were talking about,
that's when the most impressionable when
it comes to the developing of the brain,
right?
>> A lot of this has like she's got like a
stylistic throwback vibe to like the
70s. Like you look in her music videos,
it's like all kind of 70s themed. And I
think maybe she's trying to like throw
back to like the pinup girls probably,
>> right? Good point.
>> Yeah. So, here's her cards up close with
obviously the the boots just with the
high heels and and the the handcuffs,
which is actually part of her show as
well. Later on, I'll I'll show you
something about this, but basically she
she has a segment of series of shows
that she was doing where you're too hot
and you need to be arrested and then she
comes out with pink handcuffs and like
handcuffs somebody in her show.
>> So, it's a little bit of a sexual
reference as well. And by the way,
that's also a very much of a distortion
of how God has created sexuality
>> because it's not about handcuffing
somebody and doing kinky stuff. It's
about loving your spouse, serving your
spouse, being there for your spouse, and
showing God to your spouse,
>> which is the real definition of love,
right? It's others focused. For God so
loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son. So, it's like the picture
that the Bible's building up of love is
the act of giving. And in a marriage,
it's like you're giving this other
individual pleasure. And what the
devil's done is he's rebanded rebranded
this, called it lust, tries to put it in
the same thing, right? It's what can I
take from you?
You don't care if
that's why sexual mixed with violence is
the worst combination of things. I mean,
Charles Manson went and murdered a bunch
of people and he said that's what
debased his mind
getting pleasure off of somebody's pain.
>> And this is my issue with some of
Sabrina Carpenters's music videos is
that it is violence mixed with sexuality
and it's very, very bad for the brain.
Okay, so here's an article of a mom who
went to one of Sabrina Carpenters shows
and she actually approves of her show.
She's very much for it and she's also
very much for all the little girls that
show up. She actually reveals the age
that she saw. A few weeks prior to the
2024 US presidential election, I found
myself at a concert venue screaming,
singing, "I'm so effing horny."
alongside 15,000 fellow Sabrina
Carpenter fans, most of whom fell
solidly within the 12 to 18 age bracket.
>> Wow.
>> Amid a sea of feather bows, rhinestones,
and every shade of pink on the color
wheel, I was most charmed to see little
girls in their adorable homemade outfits
excitedly walking handinhand with their
dads or moms or cool aunts. A joyful
90minute celebration of femininity and
fun.
>> I don't understand this world anymore.
This is not my home.
>> What happened to this place?
>> This is where we know we're living like
in the end times.
>> You know what I mean? Like if if if if
the end is going to be worse than any
other time, we know like you know Sodom
and Gomorrah had people showing up like,
you know, bring that person out. We want
to have our way with them, right? Like
that's a pretty bad time. Yeah. And if
we're heading towards something worse
than that, this is what's catalysting
that.
>> Yeah.
>> So it goes on. Vogue also wrote about
the age of kids that follow Sabrina
Carpenter on social media. They say her
famous line in Espresso, I'm working
late cuz I'm a singer, captured Tik Tok
fans in the spring with over 107 million
posts using the sound bite. 67% of her
Tik Tok audience is 18 to 24 years old
with 577%
on Instagram per lefty. So, a little bit
older, but they notice. But still,
that's the that age when you're trying
to decide who you're going to become in
life, right? You're off to go to college
and you're hanging out with other
people. You're trying to figure out who
am I? And this is the kind of stuff that
they listen to and follow. And then
Spotlight, uh, they have a publication
called Luminate. They collected data on
what age group listens to Sabrina
Carpenter. Okay, so this is what they
said. 31% of Gen Z listens to her and
34% of millennials.
>> Am I Gen Z?
>> I don't even know what generation I am.
No,
>> I'm I'm like on the one end of
millennial.
>> I'm I'm technically millennial, but I'm
like early millennial.
>> I'm on the other end of millennial. No,
no, no, no. Gen Z is like like 18 and
stuff like that.
>> Oh,
>> unless you want to be 18.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, Gen Z is after
millennial. Yeah. So, you would be um
what's before millennial?
>> Oh, I'm that old now.
>> Gen X. I think it's
>> Gen X. X.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think it's Gen X. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. You're probably Gen X. So,
>> okay. I was trying I was trying to
picture like which demographic is this
that's actually paying attention to
this. Okay.
>> Joseph barely teenagers. Millennials are
your guys' age.
>> But it's a big broad range.
>> Millennial is pretty broad. Yeah.
>> Because like I think millennial goes up
to I'm 31. I think it goes up to like
29ish. Yeah.
You know, you know what's interesting
about the the specific uh um focus of
music videos is that
>> number one, viewing sexually explicit
content, the more times you view it is
actually what changes you more. Like if
you just watch something one time and
you're like exposed to it one time,
>> yeah, there might be some some change
there, but like it's the continual
viewing of things that changes you.
>> It's kind of like um you're walking
through a field. If you walk through it
one time, you're going to push some of
the grass down, but you're not really
gonna, you know, make a path. Now, if
you walk it every single day,
>> eventually you're going to have a
little, you know, looks like a deer path
going through there.
>> But as you do things more and more
consistently, eventually it becomes a
six-lane highway
>> in your brain. Those neuronal
connections in there, they they get more
and more firmly established.
>> And so, by viewing some of this this
content,
>> but what are people doing with music? M
you're listen they're listening to it on
repeat and some people are sitting here
watching these music videos on repeat.
They'll have it sitting thrown up on
their TV and they sit there and play it
and play it and play it.
>> And then if you look at the link between
how music changes the brain. Music
itself is very powerful.
>> The music itself can actually cause some
changes there. It'll obviously it'll
change your mood. If you want to be
happy, listen to happy music, right? You
want to be sad, listen to somber,
melancholy music, right? So when you're
sitting there and you're listening to a
specific type of music, it does more
than just impact your mood. There's
actually some research out there that
shows it makes deeper changes than just
your mood in your brain.
>> Yeah.
>> So if you're sitting there and you're
watching on repeat continuously
explicit content and then you're also
combining that with music. The devil has
this fine-tuned down to a science of how
to change people's brain chemistry, how
to change their mind so that they're not
focusing. I mean, why does the Bible say
was it in 1 Corinthians where it talks
about by beholding
>> Christ, we become changed, right?
>> Um,
>> similarly, I think if we're not
beholding Christ and we're beholding the
things of this world,
>> not things that, you know, whatsoever
things are pure, whatsoever things are
of good report, that type thing. If
we're not viewing those type things,
>> I think it changes us in the opposite
direction.
>> It% does. Yeah.
>> Time magazine did a study on um you
know, celebrity worship, people that pay
attention to particular celebrities for
an x amount of time. Um I think the
study was was spread out over 10 years.
And they found that the more that that
that you focused on those people, the
more you assimilated their
characteristics in yourself. And and
that just makes sense. I mean, if you
read the Bible and you learn about Jesus
and you're thinking about his life and
you're constantly doing that, your
character will want to be molded into
that. If you're thinking of some
celebrity, your character is going to
get molded into that.
>> So, remember we were talking about uh
that that mom that went to the concert
and she saw a bunch of little girls.
>> No, let's look at a little real life
example of a girl who went there and the
parents took her there and I don't know,
she's like six, I'm guessing. So, that's
like barely older than your son, Alex.
Um, it is It is pretty wild.
>> It is Chloe's first ever concert.
>> We are taking her to Sabrina Carpenter
and she is like obsessed with her song.
She knows every word. She's just so
excited. So, I can't wait to take her.
>> Right. So, tell us what is exciting
happening today. Chlo,
>> what?
>> Sabrina Carpenter.
>> Oh, that sounded like you were saying a
swear word.
>> At night, we are going with
>> Goodland.
>> Cousins. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> You're not.
>> And we're going to a concert.
>> I'm going singer.
>> Listen. Can you Can you show us you're
not right? Go on. And then Chloe, tell
us
>> at night.
>> No, we've already at night. We are
going.
>> Where are you going? Who you going to
see?
>> We're going to see the rain.
>> What's your favorite song of hers?
>> I feel like yours would be either Taste
or Coincidence. What do you think?
>> What one do you know the words to? Do
you want to sing us a little Sabrina
Carpenter song?
>> Okay, go at the concert.
>> And introducing Sabrina Carpenter.
[Applause]
Please be aggress.
>> I thought she was going to be like one
of the youngest here. I keep looking and
so many really young kids are here. I
don't think people know like obviously
cuz there is society where it's really
rude and I was a little bit worried
about bringing her at first but she's at
an age where it just got it completely
go over her head thank goodness. So I
thought oh I probably one of the only
ones that bring her and she's really
young but it's not. There's actually so
many
>> you know this is like casting seeds
right um I think you know we talk about
that often in Christianity where we're
casting these seeds of of that it will
hopefully get watered and somebody will
grow up in a life with Jesus right.
>> Yeah. But man, it's like what kind of
imagery gets planted into that young
kid's mind that it's like as they
develop and change and now they're
confronted with these life-changing
choices and all that kind of stuff. It's
like you've programmed in your mind,
like you mentioned with the pathway,
you've made deep grooves in your mind.
>> Lord have mercy.
>> But I notic it with your kids too, Alex,
that they very much copy what you guys
do.
>> Oh, 100%. Yeah.
>> So they they copy what they see and they
copy what you say everything.
>> Well, they copy everything and that's
actually like a programmed response from
a neuroscience standpoint. So you think
about um humans are very visual
creatures. And so light will flash in
through your eyes. You receive so much
information with your eyesight flashes
back along your optic nerve and it
actually goes to the back of your head,
your occipital lobe. And then that
information kind of cascades forward and
actually where you have your higher
decision-making capacities in your
frontal lobe. just behind your forehead.
Um, and that's where you make your
higher executive decisionmaking. You
know, is this right? Is this wrong?
Should I do this? Should I not do this?
>> But a system that, uh, everybody has
when they're a little kid, um, that is
very powerful is is mirror neurons.
>> And mirror neurons basically are where,
um, you're you mimic what you see
happen. And so you can see this with a
little kid and I see it with my kids
where um you'll sit there and the very
earliest form of it most of the time is
is in an infant you sit there and you'll
smile at them and eventually they'll
start to smile back.
>> Right. Right.
>> And um that that kind of behavior of
mirroring what somebody else is doing
progresses and it gets more complicated.
You know initially you're just kind of
waving at somebody. If you wave at a
little baby eventually they'll start
kind of waving back and sometimes it'll
take them a second. They'll sit there
and they'll watch you with this
quizzical look on their face while
you're sitting there waving at them and
then maybe you walk away and then like
maybe 30 seconds or a minute later
>> they start doing it
>> and they start waving, right? But as you
get older that that mirroring
>> actually becomes more complicated.
>> And so you'll have a little kid like a
5-year-old, he wants to go out and he
wants to mow the lawn cuz he's seen you
mowing the lawn.
>> He wants to help fix the tractor cuz he
saw you working on the car or something
like that. And so as you as you
progress, this behavior becomes more
complex.
>> And in adolescence, it's at its at its
height where you're sitting there and
you're able to mirror complex
uh things that are going down. But as
you age and as you get out of
adolescence, you lose the plasticity in
your brain
>> where you're you're more likely to
mirror something immediately. And you
know, you're you're kind of like, nah, I
kind of know what I want to do. I'm not
just going to immediately go copy
everybody. I know what I want to do with
my life. I know what I'm going to do.
>> Um, and so
>> these music videos and these kids are at
their some of the most impressionable
time of their life.
>> And that's what that means
impressionable is is it's really based
off of that system, right?
>> Where um if they watch that, they're
more likely to act that out and
especially the more times they're
exposed to it. But even one concert
experience like this, do you think that
little kid is going to remember it? This
high energy
>> environment, they're going to remember
that.
>> Um, and and how is that going to impact
them and their thoughts about their own
worth, their own self value,
>> right?
>> Their own identity, how is that going to
impact them as they age?
>> Yeah. You you think of the parents role
in here. I mean, just in a rubber
stamping something is okay. If your
parents are condoning that,
>> you know, it's like without even saying
anything, your kids's already going,
"Oh, mom and dad like this." And
>> yeah, I can run around in in strip strip
club underwear and it's okay. So, yeah.
And this is not the batch that the
parents at all. I mean,
>> you know, we just live in a sinful world
and a sinful society. And and I do
believe that most parents want to do
what's best for them. It's just that
when you don't have the Bible as your
guide for your life,
>> you know, it's it's it's yeah, you're
you're walking down a different path
than what God has intended. So, let's
take a look at a couple more clips from
Sabrina Carpenter where there's some
kids at the concerts and uh look at uh
how they react. Now, first here you see
a clip where Sabrina Carpenter, like I
said earlier, she does these arrests at
her stage where she gives people these
pink handcuffs because they're they're
too hot. So she has to arrest them and
then she also drops her clothes. But
look at the kids the age that are there
that are beholding this.
[Music]
[Applause]
>> Can you tell everybody your name?
>> Penny.
Penny. And then next to you is Ray. This
was so weird. It's like double trouble
and now my clothes are falling off
because I'm really overwhelmed.
>> She dropped her clothes. Is that what's
around her feet
>> and she's stepping out of them?
>> Yes. So, she basically this is that she
does at every single of this series of
concerts that she was doing where Yeah.
she like arrests someone with these pink
handcuffs.
>> But in this moment, I think what
happened was that she was trying to like
talk to this one girl and there were two
little girls behind her and when she
asked the girl in front of her name, I
think that's what happened. the girls
behind her responded and said, "This is
my name." And so she starts interacting
with the younger girls and asked them
for their name. And then she's like,
"Well, I'm feeling so overwhelmed. My
clothes are dropping off." And then she
drops her clothes.
>> And then she gives them the hand I don't
know if she did this not in recording
whether she gave the pink handcuffs to
the little girls who are minors or not.
I don't know if but that's normally what
she does is she hands that person the
pink handcuffs.
>> I mean, you know, these shows are
crafted like with people sitting around
in a room and going, "Okay, this is what
you're going to do next." I mean, they
know they know exactly what they're
doing. All yeah, all scripted down down
to the thing. And if you went to all
these concerts, you would see similar
things happen at most all of them.
>> I'd like to be in the room to hear them
try to like mention why they want to do
this. Like
>> like why do you think that's a good
idea?
>> I mean, just the visual and I know my
clothes are coming off now, you know,
and it's like the concert's progressing
>> with thousands of people observing that
is strange. So then obviously we have
the the album Manchild. Uh we've saw a
part of this interview before where she
was in CBS and she talks a little bit
about her album Manchild and the
sensuality in the song and and what she
thinks about it.
>> There's a lot of sensuality in your song
deliberately. So
>> yeah, I think um that just happens so
naturally.
>> Does it?
>> When I started, you know, becoming more
sexual as a person, I think it's just
something that's a part of life. You
want to write about it. I didn't realize
it was as taboo of a topic until I
started writing about it more freely.
>> Um, and then you sort of get into that
place where you're like, you know, I'm I
I feel as though I'm being pretty
harmless and I'm being pretty playful
with the way that I say these things.
So, so I do I just I just do what makes
me happy, what makes me laugh, what
makes me feel like, you know, girls in
their room are going to be
>> getting ready to. And I think that
that's that's a lot of what gets me
excited.
>> Do you guys think it's harmless? I I I
kind of want to explore a little bit of
what she just said there right there.
Girls in their room getting ready to and
she didn't finish the sentence like
getting ready to what? Go to school.
>> No, she meant like getting ready to her
music.
>> They're listening to her music getting
ready for
>> But did you hear what she said? She said
um uh I just do what makes me happy.
>> Do you know what the the first rule of I
think it's uh the church of Satan is?
>> Interesting.
>> Do what thou wilt.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Shall be the whole of the
law. That's the whole of the law, right?
>> Which is opposite of God's law,
>> right? And so it's like just do whatever
makes me happy.
>> Mhm.
>> And
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. They don't have to be part of that
church to to perpetuate their, you know,
kind of modality. That's what they're
into. And
>> that's it's all about yourself.
>> I I really think whether it's as
straightforward as Satan, demons
visiting you, whatever or not, I don't
know. But I really think a lot of these
people come to a fork in the road where
they have to make a choice. You know, uh
we have some videos on this where it's
very obvious that some people have
explicitly said or you can find out that
they have sold their soul to Satan.
>> Now, I don't want to make this statement
about Sabrina Carpenter because I don't
know if she did or not. And like I said,
it could be not as much of a forward,
hey, if you do this, I'll give you this.
It could be a thing of of constant
choices and knowing that this there's
this dark side to this world, but if you
make these choices, then you will get
this. I don't know how that will go
because Satan wraps it up differently
for whatever the person is enticed
>> to accept.
>> But I do really believe that that world
is not from God.
>> Well, to be honest, it doesn't matter if
it was directly coming from a command of
Satan or not, right? like that that can
be speculated and and you know you could
probably conspiracy theory figure it out
but
>> what's the fruit of that
>> I mean you're you're told to judge by
the fruit you'll know them right and so
you know this thing is causing this kind
of an outcome and however they got to
that point to think that this is okay it
really is irrelevant outside of the like
you know where this is going to
ultimately impact little girls
>> and And this is ultimately why we need
Christ living in us is because the heart
is deceitfully wicked above all things.
And so if we if we
>> it doesn't even have to be Satan or a
demon making him do this because
>> humanity we now after the fall we have
the capability for evil because the
heart is deceitfully wicked.
>> Um and so the only way we we get rid of
that is we ask Christ to come into our
hearts and dwell in us by his holy
spirit.
>> We need a new heart.
>> Right. So, Alex, you brought up earlier
2 Corinthians 3:18 that says, "But we
all with unveiled face beholding us in a
mirror, the glory of the Lord, are being
transformed into the same image from
glory to glory just as by the spirit of
the Lord." So, by beholding Christ
through his work, through prayer,
through spending time with him,
surrounding ourselves with fellow
Christians who reflect Christ, we become
changed into his image. And the opposite
happens as well. So, I actually found
this uh clip by Michael Spitzer. He's a
professor of music at the University of
Liverpool. He talks about mirror neurons
which you have brought which you have
brought up already
>> and but from a musical point of view.
Listen to this.
>> We also love to imitate rhythm and
that's due to the existence of mirror
neurons in our brains.
When the brain sees an action, you don't
have to move to experience that motion
in your brain because the mirror neurons
are responding sympathetically. We've
always had an instinctive faculty to
imitate. Um, we call it mimmesis.
Yawns are contagious. If I see you
yawning, I yawn back. But also emotions
are contagious. When I hear a sad song,
my body, my mirror neurons are are
instinctively sympathizing. I'm
mimicking. are mirroring the sadness of
the song isn't just acoustic. It's also
encoding the behavior which we associate
with sadness which is which is grieving.
>> Fascinating.
>> Mhm.
>> I always understood mirror neurons as
like movies, TV, you know, like if I see
someone shoot something and my brain
basically detects it as as a similar
thing, right? Like it's have a hard time
to differentiate from that. But yeah,
with music, very similar effect.
>> It's an it's an excellent um video clip.
I I I really appreciated what he talked
about earlier on in this one where he
said like how does a whale move? A whale
moves in like a very slow big arcing
thing like this. How does a whale sound?
So it's making the same sound as it is
actually moving a bird. How does a bird
sound? What does a bird do in its
motion?
>> And I was like really interesting that
we as humans like we're, you know, we're
like put the put the nose to the grind
cone and go and do the work, right? And
so we like this driving music that's
like it's it's interesting. But he was
linking the emotion that you're
watching. It's it's so much more than
just hearing the words or the sound. I
mean, it's it's a full experience that's
immersing your body into it. And and
like you brought up earlier, it's
literally cutting to the chase and
bypassing all sorts of things in your
brain and just like hitting you right at
your core.
>> So going back to the study of Dr. Wright
and Michelle Krak from the media and
migration lab at the University of
Florida. This is something else. They
said that previous research has found
that listening to sexually explicit
lyrics is associated with greater
likelihood of initiating intercourse
during adolescence and frequently
viewing videos containing sexual imagery
is related to more sexually permissive
attitudes. Popular media is believed to
play a critical role in the sexual
socialization of young people in that
adolescence consider the media to be an
important tool for learning information
about sexual activity and intercourse.
And then this one other research
contends that music, specifically rap
and hiphop have strong correlations with
risky sexual behavior and an estimated
40% to 75% of music videos contain
sexual imagery. So this is like where
they learn these things. And so
basically when they see this kind of
music and music videos, they're they're
going to be more promiscuous later on in
life. So that little girl that went to
that concert, people might think, "Oh,
it just goes over her head." But this is
where she's being educated and this is
how she actually will act out her
sexuality when she's in her adolescent
years.
>> Yep. And and that's the issue that now
you don't have to go to an explicit
website anymore to see this kind of
content. It's everywhere. And it's in
the music videos too like we were
talking about. Um and and one of the
other music videos that is more
explicit.
>> Maybe well okay. Yes, it is actually
sexually explicit. And I'll tell you
why. But this is more I would say
violently explicit. So this is a song
taste. So on the screen here you see the
start of the music video.
>> My goodness. Like all these things are
in a scrubby bowl.
>> Yeah. So,
>> is that what you call that thing?
>> Yes. I'm just like I didn't even
>> I was trying to think of the proper name
of that. But I was like
>> I didn't realize that this was there and
I was like wow that is so weird
>> random.
>> Um but yes, so a whole bunch of gnarly
looking weapons. This is the beginning
of the music video's taste. This has
millions and millions of views and she
actually did this in collaboration with
Jenny Ortega. So she, Sabrina in this
music video has to choose one of these
weapons to go delete her boyfriend and
his mistress. So yeah, you know,
everybody has these weapons in their
home. I guess I don't. I have a lofah,
but that's about it.
>> So her her boyfriend ends up dying. Uh
Sabrina and Jenn Ortega, who is the
mistress, they become friends. Of
course, there's they become two lesbians
kissing each other cuz that's what you
do apparently in all these music videos.
That's the sexually explicit content.
But here's a Instagram post on Sabrina
Carpenter's Instagram where she talks
about behind the scenes from Taste. And
so you can see that she's here with
Jenna Ortega, who played the mistress,
uh, posing with a chainsaw that's
covered with some red substance. I
blurred her belly, but you can imagine
what the red substance is. And so, yeah,
posing like they're having fun. And then
they also posted this video on YouTube
of the behind the scenes.
And if that's true,
>> I just killed that in the blue with her
own chainsaw.
[Applause]
[Music]
>> So what's really
Yeah, this is just like nuts that this
is even acceptable.
>> I mean I mean I mean but it's just like
portrayed as like we're having fun, you
know, and she basically says I just
killed that B I T C H in the blue.
meaning Sabrina with her own chainsaw.
Like when in Earth's history was this
normal vocabulary to come out of your
mouth and this was like normal to talk
about, you know?
>> It's a two-way street that they're
promoting this like promiscuous
lifestyle and then getting mad at people
that are being promiscuous.
>> See, what's shocking to me about all of
this is not so much that you have
explicit content because explicit
content, I think, has always been around
ever since the dawn of sin, right? Um, I
mean, you go back, I mean, there's
always been prostitution. There's always
been uh evil stuff like that. But what
is shocking to me about this is that
it's widely accepted in youth and in all
the rest of society,
>> which is the next generation at that
point,
>> right? And so so it's not just like some
fringe of society that's off, you know,
in some, you know, above 18, you know,
kind of special house somewhere, you
know, it's it's rampant in all of
society. And that it's so readily
available to everybody. You don't have
to click like I'm above 18 or anything
like that. It's just on YouTube.
>> Yeah.
>> And in fact, you know, it ads for it are
going to be shown across everything.
Yeah. which, you know, the ads on
YouTube and the ads on Facebook are are
horrific now.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and that they're constantly trying to
feed you that type stuff. And so to me,
that's a marker again that shows us the
day in which we're living.
>> Yeah. You know, Modern Warfare, I when
all that stuff came up years ago about
Tik Tok and should we take it off and
not allow it in this country and all
that kind of stuff. Um you know, it
being a Chinese company, when you look
at Tik Tok in China, they don't have a
ton of this kind of junk on there. They
actually have very like responsible like
people that are like promoting like
positive values and all this stuff like
this. You look at our TikTok, it's
nothing but this kind of junk and and
and basically some people have
speculated and said look they are like
modern warfare today is not like let me
show up in your country with guns and
I'm just going to muscle you. It's like
let me rot your children out and in one
generation we will so dumb them down
that we going to have this you know
superpower of people over here. And I
think that's why you see in our
entertainment stuff. I mean this is what
people care about. Nothing but the bread
and circus. Give me cheap food and give
me my entertainment.
>> Yeah.
>> And you can see it too in the comments
here where somebody says this song is so
good. Also don't blame me but this is my
favorite music video. Yikes.
>> It is my favorite Sabrina song. Well
done, Jenna and Sabrina. So proud. I've
watched the music video like three times
and I loved it. I laughed so hard when
Sabrina started to slam the voodoo doll
down to the beat. I can't stop watching
the music video taste. Like, wow. This
is
>> Wait, so there's a there's a voodoo doll
in
>> there's a voodoo voodoo doll in there as
well. Like this is
>> I missed that.
>> Yeah,
>> it's it's pretty though.
>> Yeah. Right. Exactly. Yeah. And so
that's where you're combining
spiritualism with this as well then.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Very true. Which God very
explicitly speaks against. But John 3:19
says, "And this is the condemnation that
the light has come into the world. And
men love darkness rather than light
because their deeds were evil."
>> But you know, I I I really believe in in
in Christ's power to change us, to heal
us from that darkness, from that sinful
nature, and to give us hope
>> and a better life. Um, and you know,
it's interesting because we three here
at the table are not necessarily, you
know, oh, we've been in the life in a
church our whole life and we've been
like these awesome Christians and we're
just going to like slam a bunch of
people. No, I didn't grow up Christian.
You grew up Christian and left and you
went to Hollywood actually, right, for
what 10 plus years and lived a
completely non-Christian life. And you
were raised a Christian, but I know your
story is kind of like you were chasing a
lot of the worldly things, right?
nominal nominal and in name but not
actually seeking a personal
relationship.
>> Um and then finally you realize you have
this shift in your life where you
realize what's important and you realize
there's only one person who can make you
truly happy.
>> That's right.
>> And that's Jesus.
>> Right.
>> Amen. So, so I want to bring that out
there that this applies to all of us as
well. Then Jesus spoke to them again
saying, "I am the light of the world. He
who follows me shall not walk in
darkness but have the light of life."
Another music video that's popular is
Please, please, please. Also, millions
of views. You can see in her
ex-boyfriend, actor Barry Kyogan. So,
basically in this music video, she uh
she Sabrina is getting out of jail and
she sees Barry as he's being arrested.
He goes, he's being put into jail. He's
a criminal. She bails him out. And
throughout the video, he keeps getting
himself in trouble in fight scenes, bank
robbery, and all that kind of stuff. So,
this is actually one of the very few
songs that didn't have any sexually
explicit content. But again, it's like
there's a bunch of violence in there.
Um, and this is also the song remember
when the little girl was singing just
before she went to the concert.
>> So, she was actually say they were like,
"Oh, perform a song for us." She was
singing, "Please, please, please." Oh,
>> okay.
>> Which again in the music video is full
of all these examples of things you
shouldn't be doing, bad things in
society. So, I would not want if I had a
daughter for her to be singing that kind
of song that's associated with that
video. Then of course she also did
please please please with Dolly Parton.
Um in a music video they're sitting in a
car. They're just singing a song
together. But at the end it gets really
interesting. Maybe in a bad way.
>> If you don't want to cry to my music.
Don't make me hate you.
[Music]
>> Okay. So, question.
The guy's in the back of the truck and
then right after they're sitting in the
back of the truck. So, where's the dude?
>> They killed him.
>> I don't know. But that's up to your
imagination, right? when you see
something like that.
>> Do you know one thing that really struck
me when I was watching the couple music
videos just kind of in preparation for
this is how much cigarette smoking has
like come back cuz like she's in there
and like they're all like smoking a
cigarette when
>> Charles you did that too.
>> Yeah. And like I feel like that phased
out for a while where you didn't have it
as popular because people know like yeah
that's like really bad for your health
but now it's come back as almost like a
retro vibe like a throwback. And so
there it's like kind of part of the vibe
of the video to like do that, but at the
same time again, what are you showing
people that it's okay to consume that,
right?
>> So when I first moved to Los Angeles, um
we very quickly, myself and a few
friends of ours um joined up with an
extra company and so just to get go get
on the sets and watch and observe and
stuff like this. We were extras in lots
of things. I've been music videos, all
sorts of stuff like this. There's a rep
that is walking around with cartons of
cigarettes and handing them out for free
so that you'll be in the background and
and smoking with them. They're literally
encouraging like who here wants to smoke
and who wants to do this? Yeah. And it's
just like I at first I thought that was
just weird. I was like why are you
giving everybody cigarettes? You know,
it's like they'd give them out for free
just so that you had them on video.
>> Well, it's like product placement,
right? Why do you put doing it? Yeah.
That's why certain um they stopped
allowing I think the the advertisements
of smoking in magazines and stuff,
right? Yeah.
>> I don't think that that's even a legal
thing anymore simply because people were
observing them doing it and that would
cause them to do it. So, if this is a
roundabout way of getting around that in
an entertainment way, I'm sure it's
having a profound effect on people.
>> Yeah. So, the other video that's really
popular and song is called Feather. It's
very, very violent. Um, in this video,
men all want Sabrina, but she doesn't
care. And for some reason, they keep
getting killed, which is kind of a
reference to remember music video tears.
She's like, "Oh, no, you have to die."
Cuz in my music video, they all die. You
know, it's just kind of an ongoing thing
in her music videos. And she's doesn't
really care. She's like, "Oops." Oh,
well. So before we talk about that a
little bit more, here's an interesting
study from Headlight where you know they
talk about am I at risk of becoming
violent or aggressive from this
particular music? And they say yes, it
increases aggressive thoughts. It
intensifies feelings of anger. It causes
psychological arousal. It leads to
hostile or aggressive behavior. It
creates desensitization to violence and
forms a lack of empathy simply from
watching violence in music videos, which
is what she's doing. She's portraying
all this violence in music videos. And
uh Psychology Today says that watching
videos of mass shootings or other
violent events on the news or online
makes you more prone to develop or
worsen depression, anxiety, PTSD,
chronic stress, insomnia, and increases
the chance of symptoms such as
flashbacks. Wow.
>> Yeah. And the Bible talks about do not
enjoy
um what is it?
>> Romans 1:32.
>> What does it say? It says, "Who knowing
the judgment of God, they which commit
such things are worthy of death, but not
only do the same, but take pleasure in
them that do that."
>> Exactly.
>> Meaning that if you steal, you're in
danger of the judgment of stealing. If
you take pleasure in someone stealing,
you're counted for as if you did that
yourself. So, yes, when you're watching
other people sin and you're taking like
pleasure in that, that's basically what
Paul was getting at is like you might as
well have been doing it. And I felt
convicted about that because I actually
for a while enjoyed just watching those
like police arrest videos. But I was
like, "But wait a minute. These people
are are sitting. That's why they're
getting arrested. They're committing a
crime." And now I'm actually finding joy
out of what entertainment out of
watching these people and what the
police is doing and all that kind of
stuff. And I felt strongly convicted
like no I I I should not be doing that.
Um I should not be watching this kind of
stuff.
>> You know, Journal of Experimental Social
Psychology. This was a study that was
published in this journal in 2015 and
they talk about the effects of music
with aggressive lyrics with or without
the music videos, right? So, it's just
about the lyrics and whether it had made
those listening or watching more
aggressive. So, listen to what they
said. Five decades of research have
shown clear links between exposure to
violent visual media and subsequent
aggression. However, there has been
little research that directly compares
the effects of exposure to violent
visual versus auditory media or which
has experimentally tested the effect of
violent song lyrics with musical tone
held constant. In the current study, 194
participants heard music either with or
without lyrics and with or without a
violent music video and were then given
the chance to aggress using the hot
sauce paradigm. Musical tone was held
constant across groups and a fifth
control group had no media exposure at
all. Air experimental groups on average
were significantly more aggressive than
controls. The strongest effect was
elicited by exposure to violent lyrics.
Regardless of whether m violent imagery
accompanied the music and regardless of
various person-based characteristics, a
violent music aggression link was found.
Viant lyrics had a robust effect and
aggression holding musical tone
constant. The results were similar
across three violent music video clips
from three music genres. the effect was
unddeinished holding a holding trait
aggression and personality variables
constant. So clearly there is a link and
it's a very strong link as well. So I
mean it's not just like you're being
sexually affected, you're being
influenced in that capacity and
aggressively all across the board. And
again, when you're talking about um
>> Manson uh what's the guy's name? Charles
Manson that he's like the connection
between violence and sexuality made him
rape and murder a bunch of people.
>> Mhm.
>> I mean, come on, dude. And then this is
just sugarcoated like let's have a
version like this for women now.
>> Jesus was a carpenter.
>> Yeah. So Jesus was a carpenter on the
next slide here. So what happened was we
had the music video
>> is absolutely awful.
>> She had a music video Feather, right? We
actually talked about this in a
different video.
The music video Feather is very violent,
extremely violent, right? And there's a
bunch of people that died. Now, she shot
a whole scene dressed very half naked in
a Catholic church.
>> And so when there was a bunch of outrage
about that from Catholics, she said,
"Well, Jesus was a carpenter and her
last name is Sabrina Carpenter."
>> Right? That's what she's meaning is like
Jesus is just like me. rather than I
mean that's like taking the holy and
making it profane and trying to put it
in a box like he's no nothing different.
That's what the devil's argument was
with Jesus the whole time was he was
basically like look you you have this
leg up on everybody else but if you were
put in their shoes you'd be just like
them. And it's like no Jesus proved that
that was not the case
>> and to the point where it's like he was
unjustly murdered. It was not like this
what she's meaning there.
>> So she wore this t-shirt. Jesus was a
carpenter to Coachella where she
performed. Now obviously her fans are
doing the same thing, right? Like like
monkey see monkey do. Like we talked
about mirror neurons. So now I'm seeing
you do this. There's a reason why they
put celebrities in advertisements to
sell like a perfume or something like
that. Yeah.
>> You know, it's it's obvious for that
reason because they know that it works.
So here's a fan. He wore this t-shirt to
a Madison Square Garden concert of
Sabrina Carpenter in New York City. and
see if people see you with a particular
t-shirt on like the one that I'm
wearing. You can get that at
likewear.shop.
>> Yeah. If you like,
>> you know, I might need to get one so I
can fit in. I think we need to give you
one actually.
>> Yeah. You can we put a link to your
shirt in the description.
>> Oh, there we go.
>> We have a box downstairs of t-shirts, so
you're welcome to go and thumb through
it.
>> Oh, there we go.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, then there's another
song of hers, Bet Cam, meaning
chemistry. Also, obviously overly sexual
lyrics. There's espresso, also overly
sexual lyrics, ensuring lots of half-
naked women, including herself. Um, so
it's pretty much everywhere. So, going
back to this study by the three
professors, assistant professors at the
University of Amsterdam. Check out what
they said in terms of arousal,
Reuben at all found music videos were
rated as more exciting, more exciting
and arousing than music audios.
Similarly, in terms of pleasure, Hansen
and Hansen showed that music videos
elicit a pleasurable emotion response
which is intensified by the high levels
of arousal people experience while
watching music videos. In fact, the
experience of pleasure is one of the
main reasons for adolescence to listen
to music and the same reasons probably
hold for watching music videos.
>> What are your thoughts on that, Alex?
>> Well, of course, you know, again, we go
back to humans are very visual
creatures. Yeah. So, you're sitting
there listening to something that is
making you feel happy while watching it.
Of course, you're going to get more of
an effect out of it. Um, and the problem
is is like you're getting this dopamine
hit from it.
>> Yep.
>> And as a result, you you think about we
go back to Tik Tok, uh, YouTube shorts,
Facebook reels. Um, you get this
dopamine addiction to it. eventually
your pleasure receptors in your brain
will get used to that certain level of
dopamine and it actually takes a
stronger and stronger stimuli to achieve
the same uh pleasurable effect.
>> So is there any wonder that music videos
have gotten progressively more risque
that they have gotten progressively more
profane as time has gone on because you
need a higher level of stimuli. So why
is her music so popular? It's so popular
because you start off with something
that was seemingly more mild with like
Taylor Swift. Well, who's opening for
Taylor Swift at the Aerys tour? It's
Sabrina Carpenter, right?
>> And so,
>> you know, you you have this introduction
to the next drug, if you will.
>> Yes.
>> Which is like a progression of of what
you desire that's going to hit your
brain a little harder and and make you
be like, "Oh, yeah. That's so good."
>> So, yeah. You want to go a little
deeper. Here you go. Here's the next
one. A little more. Definitely see that.
>> Yeah. Well, speaking of the next one
that's, you know, kind of in that vein,
Nonsense. Nonsense was an interesting
music video. Have you did you check out
Nonsense?
>> I haven't. That is an appropriate title
for a music video.
>> Okay. So, you know, lyrically, it only
kind of gets messy at the end. Most of
it is just like a love song saying like,
"Oh, you know, you being in love with
you got me." She said, "Ever thinking or
speaking nonsense." I think it's
thinking nonsense, but um yeah, so she
is basically seen here on the right in a
music video and she falls in love with a
dude that's actually herself on the left
and that's her male version. So
>> to me it's kind of hinting at the
hermafhrodite, you know, like male
female. It's it's
>> or that you can switch back and forth
like transgender, you know, the Bible's
clear we shouldn't dress as the opposite
gender. It speaks very explicitly about
that. Uh music video also shows a loud
nudity and scantly dressed girls. Now I
want you guys to look at this clip here
and tell me how old do you guys these
think these people are?
[Music]
How old do you guys think these other
people are?
>> They look like they're about 12 to
middle school. Yeah.
>> So, it took me a minute to realize and
to figure out in the beginning of the
music video, she is getting herself
ready for this party.
>> Mhm.
>> With two female friends, adults.
>> That's actually her female adult friends
>> dressed as boys.
>> Oh.
>> Oh, what?
>> Yes. That that one that was like vaping
wasn't a bo a girl. Nope. I mean, wasn't
a boy?
>> Nope. It's an adult female.
>> Oh, wow.
>> Well, but you know, she's actually in in
the music video tears, which I don't
know if you're going to get into this,
the music video tears, a ton of it is
transgender stuff.
>> Like a ton of it. Like you you see um uh
there's like a whole cast that comes out
and is like dancing and stuff that's all
transgender.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I think they have to push the stuff.
>> Yeah. I think the music and record
labels and everybody else is is saying
you want you want this role, you can
have this role, but this is what you're
going to do. I I guarantee you that they
are pushing these initiatives from
people that are above them that you
never hear of.
>> Yeah. And who is ultimately in control
of those people above?
>> Yeah. I mean, what a what a what a ploy,
right? Make the person popular, make a
bunch of people follow them, expose them
to kids when they're five years old, and
bam, it's like you've got a generation
now that is way more sympathetic towards
transgender issues.
>> Yeah. And and think about it, right?
Jesus was offered this when Satan came
to him and said, "I'll give you the
whole world, but bow down to me." He
said, "No."
>> Yeah.
>> But I believe every single day people
are offered this and they say, "Yes."
>> Yeah. Don't vape, kids. Just don't do
it. Like,
>> oh, it's it's horrible for your lungs.
The problem is is that we don't have uh
some of the long-standing studies that
we do from regular tobacco smoke, but
some of the vaping that's out there now,
they're seeing uh some lung effects from
it that are absolutely horrible.
>> Yeah. They say they're getting these
ripoff versions of them with these
people that are like, you know, counter
counterfeiting basically the trying to
get the the chemicals or whatever in
there and they get the mixtures wrong
and it will destroy people's lungs.
>> Well, and the other the other thing is
is with smoking, you have a good idea of
how much you smoke every day because you
have a carton and when the carton's up,
you're done. But the problem is is with
these ecigarettes and vapes, people will
be sitting there and you don't have to
stop when you go indoors because you
know you can do it inside of inside of a
store or wherever else, right? And so
people will be sitting there and they'll
be hitting it all day long
>> rather than like having to go out for
like a smoke like go to go out for my
smoke break and like you can only do
that so many times.
>> You can sit there and hit it all day
long. Unless you have people that are
getting way higher amounts of nicotine
than they ever were with tobacco, like
you know, regular cigarettes.
>> Wow.
>> But, you know, besides the cigarettes
and, you know, them vaping, I I think
what what really was kind of crazy to me
is that Yeah, it took me a hot minute to
figure out that these were actually
adults. I I thought they were biners and
here they are drinking alcohol and
smoking and you know surrounded by all
these other people at a party and you
know even Sabrina let's be honest in her
male version she looks like a teenager
>> because that's what happens when you're
a female and you dress up as a woman you
don't you look much younger because for
various reasons but also it seems like
it might even have been intentional to
make them look like kids. I mean,
everybody on set would be like, "Wow,
you look pretty young as a as a male,
you know."
>> So,
>> especially girls, cuz you don't have
facial hair.
>> Yeah, exactly. And your face faces
smoother, smoother lines.
>> So, I just think it's weird that this is
a love song that she sings, you know,
and her male version looks like a minor
to me, surrounded by minors who look
like they're going to adult party. And
but at the end, it says of the song, it
says, "This song's catchier than
chickenpox is. I bet your house is where
my other sock is. Woke up this morning,
thought I'd write a pop hit. How quickly
can you take your to clothes off pop
quiz
again? It's I know it's adults, but they
look like boys.
>> Yeah,
>> that to me is weird. Very strange.
Including Sabrina Carpenter, who is like
her her counterpart in this music video
looks to me like a minor.
>> How does the Bible describe it? Like
it's confusion when it's dressed like
that. Babylon. Yeah.
>> So embrace Babylonian confusion.
>> Exactly.
>> This is literally a Babylonian mindset.
Confusion.
>> Yeah. And then also in this clip here,
you can see Sabrina Carpenter. She's
joking with her female friend, but
again, the female friend looks like a
minor. And listen to what she says to
him.
>> You've been trying to get me for years,
Paul. And you know what? You're not my
type.
>> No, I've been thinking about you
forever.
>> So she says, you know, you've been
wanting me for years, Paul. And you know
what? You're not my type. And then her
female friend looks dressed up, looks
like a 12-year-old, says, "Oh, I've been
thinking about you for real." So,
>> it's a bit weird. It's a bit weird. Here
you can see her female friends dressed
up as boys. They look like children and
they're drinking like he literally looks
like he's 12 years old like you guys
said. So, she I should say. Yeah. Bit
strange. So, this is a quote from Bob
Pitman. He is one of the founders of
MTV. Actually, this is an old quote, but
boy does this really say what the music
industry is up to. We're dealing with a
culture of teenage babies. They can
watch TV, do their homework, and listen
to music all at all at the same time.
The strongest appeal you can make is
emotional. If you can get their emotions
going, make them forget their logic,
you've got them. At MTV, we don't shoot
for the 14-year-old. We own them.
>> Pretty confident.
>> Founder of MTV. I grew up on MTV.
>> Mhm. And I did too.
>> It's bad.
>> And that's what that goes back to what I
was saying where you are the product
nowadays. And in today's digital age is
the viewer, the person consuming it is
the product.
>> Yeah. And they don't care how train
wrecked your life is down the road. They
just care about you watching how many
hours you watch and
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I want to wrap it up
here. Hosea 1 vers2. The story of Hosea
is fascinating to me because basically
Hosea is a prophet in the Bible and
Hosea is a man of God and he is asked
told by the Lord go and marry a
prostitute. And this prostitute was
symbolic of the people of Israel as they
were
symbolically speaking committing
adultery, fornication on the Lord,
right? because they were going after all
of these false gods and and and turning
their backs on the Lord and these
statues like today we think that is so
strange. Why would people do that? In a
western society, we think of that that
but there's still other cultures where
this happens where you basically make a
little statue out of wood or or clay and
say now there's a god in there, right?
And that's what they were doing. And so
God said to Hosea, "Go and marry this
prostitute as the symbol of people who
are going astray from me, committing
adultery on me. But I am going to show
you my love for my people as as like
Hosea having to marry that prostitute
that God runs after us, wants us, wants
a relationship with us, desires that."
So Hosea 1:2 says, "When the Lord began
to speak by Hosea, the Lord said to
Hosea, go take yourself a wife of
harlotry and children of harlotry, for
the land has committed great harlotry by
departing from the Lord." But then 3:1
says, "Then the Lord said to me, go
again, love a woman who is loved by a
lover and is committing adultery, just
like the love of the Lord. for the
children of Israel who looked to other
gods and loved the raisin cakes of the
pagans. So I bought her for myself for
15 shekels of silver and one and one
half homers of barley. And I said to
her, "You shall stay with me many days.
You shall not play the harlot, nor shall
you have a man. So too will I be toward
you." But you know the prostitute,
she left Hosea multiple times. multiple
times for other men. I mean, that must
be heartbreaking. We are all married
here and I'd be absolutely broken to
pieces if my husband cheated on me and
let alone if that person did that
multiple times. But Hosea kept bringing
her back. And that's a symbol of what
God does to us. And it's interesting
that in prophecy, in Bible prophecy, the
unfaithful woman is actually a symbol of
unfaithful Christians to God. when we
turn our backs on him and that in here
in the world of music and fame and
celebrities, you have a woman like
Sabrina Carpenter who dresses very
provocatively and people worship her and
basically turn their backs on God to run
after this other woman.
But God has a desire to bring everybody
including Sabrina Carpenter home in his
arms, right? And he is running after
everyone and saying, "Come back to me."
>> So,
>> well, you know, I think uh Christ died
for her as well.
>> Amen. Absolutely.
>> And so, we shouldn't view her with any
level of hatred or anything like that or
like, oh, why could you be doing this
type thing? Instead, we should say it's
very sad. It saddens God and we should
be viewing it with
>> we don't want this being consumed by
other people. But, you know, we should
be praying for her that she'll she'll be
able to to to change um and that God
will prevent
>> uh this evil from going out and
deceiving too many people.
>> Yeah. Clearly, she has either thought
about Jesus because putting on your
t-shirt like that is like, you know, but
yeah, you'd hope that that that God
would reach her in whatever way that he
can keep knocking on the door of her
heart. And and when we get to heaven,
I'm sure that's exactly what we'll see
is God was trying to win all these
people as well. And right
>> you know how many people are praying for
somebody like this is Sabrina Carpenter
like you know Lord please like reach her
heart as well and open her eyes to some
of the influence that she has. And you
know I think um the the deeper you go in
destroying other people's lives. I think
there's probably a real psychological
damage there that's hard to turn around.
But look, it's not impossible. Paul was
killing Christians, dragging them out in
the street and then he became one of the
biggest mouthpieces for God. So, um I
think that it is possible and um we just
our duty is to pray for those people.
>> Amen. Yeah. And you said knocking on the
door of her heart of all of our hearts.
Revelations 3:20 says, "Behold, I stand
at the door and knock. If anyone hears
my voice and opens the door, I will come
into him and dine with him and he with
me." You know, Jesus Jesus is knocking.
He's a gentleman. He's not like Satan
who is just like, I'm going to you have
give me one crack and I'm going to just
barge the door open and you're mine. He
doesn't steal our hearts. Jesus is
knocking and he's just asking, "Will you
let me in?"
>> You have to do that daily. It's dying to
self daily like what Paul talks about.
Um, but when we open the door up and we
invite Christ in, one of the best ways
that we can invite him in is asking,
number one, but also reading the Bible
because because by doing that, it's
basically showing to the world and it's
showing to the the watching angels that
are out there
>> this person, they're earnestly seeking
me. I I'm going to give them give him my
Holy Spirit. I mean, that's what what
God can do. And so, uh, if we decide to
go our own way though, if we decide to
sin, you know, to to go after and chaste
whatever that we want rather than what
Christ wants,
>> we're essentially saying, you know, I
did invite you in, but I'm going to show
you to the door now. It's time for you
to go.
>> But he's always willing to come back in
if we invite him back because he is so
patient with us.
>> How many times you hear, you know, like,
just turn from your wicked ways and and
and I will accept you back. You know,
it's like God's plea. It seems like he's
never like, "Oh, sorry. You went too far
and you're not you're not welcome back
here." He's just like like, "Stop doing
those evil things and turn to me."
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. I really believe that we are super
close to when Jesus comes back. And when
you study prophecy and and we do have um
a um
a playlist on our channel as well that
kind of where we discuss some prophecy.
you have a really cool channel called
Heritage and Hope where you discuss a
lot of Bible prophecy and and I want to
make sure we give a big shout out to
your channel because you have a lot of
>> like like like frequent updates
>> on what's happening to show you we are
this close to the second coming.
>> We're very close.
>> Praise God for that that we are. You
know,
>> it's really cool to see you guys really
tackle prophecy in a deep way and and
how much research you've done in the
learning Latin, reading the documents,
having the physical books. I mean,
seriously, if you guys have an interest
in prophecy, you have to check out these
guys' channel. It's amazing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Definitely want to drop a
link for that in the description because
I think if we want to have a close
relationship with Jesus, one of the ways
is to watch your guys' channel. And I
mean it from the bottom of my heart.
like you guys have really stuff that I
think uplifts Christ and brings you
close to Jesus. But yeah, I really want
to share just if Jesus is this close, I
love the statement that when we get to
heaven, we will realize heaven was cheap
enough. Meaning it was worth giving
everything up for this.
>> Yeah. and that when we realize at some
point in the future that we were on the
wrong side and that we've given heaven
up for this,
>> it's like
>> I think you'll be heartbroken like
you've never been before.
>> Yeah.
>> And you cannot describe imagine the
horror you will experience realizing the
joys of Jesus that that you've missed
out on. And Jesus doesn't force himself
upon anybody. Like I said, he knocks.
And the choice is really up to us.
>> Mhm.
>> And all he's saying is like, "Hey, I'm
knocking. Will you open the door?"
>> Yep.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.